Bachelorette frontrunner Jordan Rogers  still dating everywhere this man when I  say I'm falling in love with you him  Jourdan and Jojo Fletcher have a strong  connection on the show but does he put a  ring on her finger in the end et has  learned Jordan might still be connecting  with other women currently on the  exclusive dating app riah here's a  screenshot we obtained looks like it's  Jordans profile but Rogers denies he's  still using the dating app he took to  Twitter on Wednesday and posted a  lengthy statement claiming he  deactivated his profile immediately  before filming The Bachelorette started  and hasn't used it since they wrapped  however an ET source who uses riah  spotted the former football pro on the  app last week and interestingly this  week on the show we got a sneak peek at  the season finale jojo appears to say  goodbye to someone she falls hard for